[Music]
the united states stands for an idea
whose time is now
ronald reagan will win tonight what a
schmuck
i think i want to be an artist when i
grow up going to be an artist if you
want to be nothing's going to stop you
you're going to college he'll have
dinner with kings if he plays his cards
right
i really like your stickers my
stepfather gave him to me he's in the
air force that's so cool
how dare you a minister to you
are you not to associate with him again
what do you mean why
i think you know what i mean
my parents are sending me to my
brother's school this hoodie
in this institution you can be anything
you want to be it won't be because of a
handout it'll be because you earned your
way there
someone's bugging you what is it
sometimes kids say bad words about the
black kids
who's that
somebody from my old school
did they ever come to your house
what'd you do when that happens
obviously nothing of course
you think that's smart
my mother you know when we came over
here we didn't have much why'd she come
here because i wanted to kill her that's
why
there were soldiers and sometimes they
go out looking for jews
they hated us then they still hate us
third god and bolton became over here to
america the land of dreams
you just want me to be like you i want
you to be a whole lot better than me
life is unfair
be thankful when you get a leg up you
make the most of your break and do not
look back all my hopes are with you and
your brother for my whole life
[Music]
[Applause]
next time though schmuck said anything
bad about those kids we're gonna say
something
you're gonna be a mensch okay firm
handshake okay give me a hug
you